hey everybody how's it going I have seen
plenty of flipping videos in the past
and I thought I would give it a shot
usually I stay away from flipping
because I don't like choosing the items
to flip I think I'm going to lose money
and it's just not worth it usually to me
but a friend of mine told me about some
websites that actually list items for
you to flip it does cost money and I'm
going to be previewing one today so I'm
going to start with 100 Mil and I'm only
going to use items previewed on the
website to make uh the flipping go much
faster and for me to not lose any money
uh the website will literally just tell
me which items to buy and sell I'll just
buy and sell them and we'll see how much
we can make in 1 hour so here's the
actual website it lists every item in
the game you can look up and one of the
advantages of course is that uh it
updates prices every 10 minutes where
the grand exchange has inaccurate and
slower prices uh the website actually
has basically as accurate as you can get
prices and I think it's going to be real
time in the next week or so they're
making a huge update and I think a lot
of features are actually free but I am
going to be showcasing two paid features
because they're you know the best so two
features I'm going to be using highest
margins and high volume items so I'm
just going to pick things from those
lists I'm going to buy a lot obviously
of the high volume items and I'm going
to try to flip some of the highest
margins let's just go there now okay so
as you guys can see there are you know
hundreds of suggested items items ranked
by like what's best and what's like what
you should flip basically so we're going
to go right to the top and we're going
to we're going to see if we can't uh
make a lot of money oh that's so clutch
one of the infinity bottoms sold I think
that's like an automatic hopefully like
330k that's what uh the margin is
supposed to be we might as well just
abort one of these offers I'm guessing
the dragon yeah let's try selling this
for a little bit higher
oh the infinity bottoms just sold so
that's like an auto 300K profit right
there I don't even know if it'll it will
pop up that's an easy 300K it's been
like 7 minutes okay now I'm going to try
the hat so I should buy it for like
okay the infinity hat just bought hell
yeah this is going pretty well so I
think I can make like 200 plus with
infinity hats okay wait what did I buy
this for 5 mil and 13k good thing right
now it's going for 5.2 mil hell yeah so
let's do
[Music]
51 uh 88 I feel like a freaking uh a
stock Trader on Wall Street right now
but then I realized boom I'm in my room
playing RuneScape talking to myself and
I'm proud of
it oh hell yeah the infinity bottoms bot
again so the infinity bottoms are by far
my best item right now ooh the staff of
the Deads are coming in so if this
actually works I'll be making about 100K
per staff of the dead and they're sold
kind of rapidly like a lot of people
need Staff Of the Deads guys stuff
wasn't selling or buying so I decided to
take a 35 minute break
and hell yes hell yes okay so a lot of
stuff bought okay these blow pipes were
bust no more uh infinity bottoms but I
think I'm going to be able to make a lot
of profit off of this stuff so let's
collect that and let's uh let's sell all
this stuff for some profit here the
Gilded boots are in I think that's a lot
of profit so I bought these gilded boots
for
661 sold them for 676 I've got 10 more
minutes in the hour but I'm getting a
little bit addicted so I should probably
stop this arams offer although the arams
is going to be a really good item I
think cuz you make like 80 do 100K
profit on each and there are actually
quite a few being bought and sold right
now oh well so I'm going to quickly get
this back I'm going to sell both of
these and we'll see how much profit we
made hell yeah this came in like 30
seconds after the hour so everybody
going be like cheating but it was it was
an hour and 30 seconds let's just say um
but so I don't know exactly how much
money we made let's
see okay this is not bad at all all so
we made
1.57 mil in 1 hour 1.57 mil is
comparable to running nature runes you
know mining runid or is much less than
that Zorra is a little bit better but if
you think about the time I spent
actually flipping was closer to 20
minutes and the rest of the time you
know I took a break for 35 minutes
because stuff wasn't buying right away
uh so it's kind of ridiculous that I
could make one .57 mil in 1 hour
essentially AFK for more than half of it
I should not have reloaded the page but
I did and look at what's at the top with
a massive juicy margin third age plate
bodies so if I could actually pull this
flip off I will make quite a bit of
money now G tracker the website I'm
using like constantly rotates through
the items and the margins are always
changing so seriously I was almost done
editing the video and I reloaded the
page
and okay I I got to go for it I got to
go for the play poot okay so let's just
go for the big boy third age plate
body the torsal are in oh my God wait I
got the third age plate body I actually
got the third age plate
body oh that's pretty clutch actually
holy I bought all of the odium
shards and look one has already sold for
quite a bit of profit the staff of the
dead has already bought as well this is
going to be a good day oh my God this is
seriously going for
74.2 mil so we're going to put it for $
7398 so if we got this offer like let's
look at what we bought it for 71 mil
71.2 mil 73.9 mil that would be what 2.7
mil profit in almost no time got the
staff of the Dead I got kind of nervous
about the odium shard and decided to
insta sell them for 10K more than I
bought them uh and I didn't know they
would actually insta sell but probably
could have made more money off that oh
well took a shower cuz I'm a grimy Noob
and guess what came in thank you Satan
no I'm just
kidding uh but the 666 did actually work
let's look at her final profit so from
the hour we didn't make that much you
know like 1.57 mil or whatever
but from an hour and about 45 minutes we
made 3.9 mil so it's there's some luck
involved there's some timing involved
but 3.9 mil in an hour and 45 minutes
were like 20 minutes of that moneymaking
was Hands-On and the rest was AFK that
is good moneymaking all right back on GE
tracker website I thought I would show
you guys quickly how to get premium and
talk a little bit more about the site
when you first sign up for the site you
get a two-day free trial so you can use
all the the features that I have shown
in the video and test them out uh and
decide if you want to spend those it's
like2 or two years EUR a month seriously
that's like not a bad price I would say
if you do want to upgrade to premium
it's right here uh in the flip finder
upgrade to premium it's super easy so
I'm not actually affiliated with GE
tracker at all um but they did pay me a
small sum of money to make the video I
just want to be transparent there the
link to GE tracker is in the description
if you guys want to check the site out
that would be cool otherwise here are
some more videos of mine to check out
boom all right if you guys enjoyed the
video leave a like and I will see you
guys in the next one bye